I wasn't sure whether to talk about this
next story we've spoken about Candace
Owens before she's this very well-funded
conservative woman a trump supporter she
is anti black lives matter despite being
black herself she works for Turning
Point USA which gets money from
everybody ranging from the NRA and the
Heritage Foundation to just individual
rich conservatives and she's become a
really useful tool of the pro Trump
right and they had this completely
failed movement called blex it which was
supposed to be the black exit from the
Democratic Party totally failed she as
far as I was told turned down debating
Kyle kolinsky and I at politican in
October alongside Charlie Kirk
although I believe on Twitter she has
claimed she doesn't know who I am so
maybe politican didn't really speak to
her about that debate I don't really
know what the truth is but what we know
for sure is that she's really ignorant
we talked about the climate change
Fiasco on the Joe Rogan program we've
talked about her basic economic
ignorance and this is really important
in the end because the right has this
system set up of really funding the
entire apparatus of Young Conservatives
and the left doesn't so people like
Candis Owens end up becoming prominent
we're similarly ignorant people on the
Left don't because there's no funding
apparatus that is artificially propping
them up so that's kind of the setup
video surfaces over the weekend of a
speaking gig that she did in London and
in the video she defends Hitler there's
really no other way to say it some
people are saying she praises Hitler
let's be a little more charitable if
it's not praised
she's certainly defending Hitler she was
asked about nationalism in Western
politics and she brings up Adolf Hitler
and how his real wrong step was becoming
a globalist take a look yeah I agree I
actually don't have any problems at all
with the word nationalism I think that
it gets the definition gets poisoned by
ëletís that actually want globalism
globalism is what I what I don't want so
when you think about whenever we say
nationalism the first thing people think
about in at least in America is Hitler
you know he was a national socialist but
if Hitler just wanted to make Germany
great and have things run well okay fine
the problem is is that he wanted he had
dreams outside of Germany he wanted to
globalize he wanted everybody to be
German everybody to be speaking German
everybody look a different way that's
not to me that's not nationalism so I'm
thinking about how we could go bad down
the line I don't really I don't really
have an issue with nationalism I really
don't I think that it's okay it's
important to retain your country's
identity and to make sure that what's
happening here which i think is
incredibly worrisome in terms of the
just the decrease in the birth rate that
we're seeing in the UK is what you kind
of want to avoid so I'm not I don't have
anything problem I have no problems with
nationalism its global isn't I try to
avoid if Hitler just wanted to make
Germany great and have things run weld
and that's fine but the problem was that
he wanted everyone speaking German well
the problem also was that he wanted to
kill Jews and killed six million Jews
and gay people and all sorts of others
how do you comment on Hitler and your
critique is that he went a little too
far beyond nationalism to global
globalism and this in a sense Pat this
should be career-ending but it's just
not going to be it's not going to be
because they've couched it in a way as
to make it appear to be less crazy than
it is it's not going to be career-ending
because she's extraordinarily
well-funded but who in their right mind
wants to hear from Candace Owens like
who even goes to watch her speak yeah
this is I think her second major gaffe
the first being her appearance on Joe
Rogan where you could tell that she had
absolutely no idea what she was talking
about on the issue of climate change and
she was just you know taking this grab
bag of conservative ideas and talking
about stuff that she really had no
business talking about this is kind of
like the second instance of that she
wasn't prepared to take a question on
nationalism and globalism and she went
off the rails I think it's important to
understand that this is what happens
when you artificially prop up ignorant
commentators Candace Owens didn't float
to the top of young right-wing activism
because in the free market of ideas she
was the best
she is propped up artificially she's the
equivalent of a sort of beneficiary of a
pundit subsidy turningpoint USA and its
funders decided we are going to find
Candace Owens and then this is what you
get someone that as I've said before
it's not even really clear that she's
actually a conservative it seems that
she was mostly non-political realized
that the young black conservative female
character is a really profitable one
because of its usefulness to the right
and you end up with someone like this
who has decided hey this is a great
character for me to play who is
surprised who is surprised that this is
what it ended up with